welcome so much
please stay married let 7,000 people
spew their lemon you only been 11 years
in the waiting
I know how I mean for you to see this up
there to see you as Deadpool yet but
it's been this one year ago - almost
today some [ __ ] in here leaked that
footage and that's why we're standing
here I mean Tim Miller on the director
who just sat back there and just shook
our heads it kind of odd just thinking
how did we get here who's that at that
moment you guys the internet fans you
guys made the studio do this you bent
their arms behind their backs
twisted their friggin necks and here we
are
let's bring everyone in first of all
let's bring Tim Miller out director Tim
Miller I'm here
and also as Vanessa beretta Baccarin
nice to meet you as Wiesel has basil my
good friend mr. TJ Miller's also here
welcome please everyone next to your
name in a world yeah you could just do
that from now on you know I do it all
the time it drives my wife and nuts all
right
so Tim let's start let's start with me
you don't want to start with you it all
starts with you start with Ryan ah get
in there give them give Tim a question
he'll be great trust me what is love
so two man named Ryan Reynolds yes Wow
she was the perfect answer these so
people love people love this character
they've been dying to see this get its
own movie for a long time this character
so movies can you can you talk about you
know what made you decide like this is
something that we're gonna do now is the
time we can do this we have the time and
resources Fox said you can make it if
you want and I said okay I mean that's
pretty much it I would have made this
[ __ ] movie any time but it had to it
had to come at the right time and the
studio was ready to make it now and I
think it's because as Ryan said it's the
fans you know he's he's through he's the
perfect character for our time I think
yeah and what Ryan why do you think
people are so in love with Deadpool I
think he I think this character and
habits a space in the comic universe
that no other person can or will ever
inhabit I mean you know it's got
everything you'd ever want yeah you know
for one I just think it's a it's an
absolute miracle that a studio let us
make Deadpool let alone a rated-r
Deadpool but yeah
but I mean you but you have to you would
have to do it this way there's no way
talking that's not the people that they
cut the big fat check did you have to
convince them event or did you or did
they just say hey man dude do whatever
you want to do with this eventually they
said that but at the beginning I mean it
is but they didn't say that at first it
was our then it was PG then it was our
again but yeah but ultimately you know
that I think they see that the world is
ready for something different no matter
what the rating is though babies will
love this it's gonna be the feel good
baby movie of the year
it's it do you feel like this is the kid
like it is you feel like Deadpool is
your soul like you feel when you when
you put on the suit you really yeah I'm
this guy this is no no that's that we
put that suit on there's just the whole
energy and atmosphere on the set changes
I mean I've not to mention the smell
thing takes a beating I mean it was just
it's and it's sort of meant to be
slightly disgusting which is also a nice
thing is all sewn up
shoddily by deadpool himself but yeah
it's uh it's definitely a game changer
you know I mean I've only ever done one
other like proper full sorry not proper
superhero movie but oh damn I didn't
have a suit you know it was uh it was a
computer-generated suit so I I never
really got to experience what that was
like to walk onto a uh Noah set fully
embody you're gonna get to talk that
much no yeah this time I don't shut up
yeah now Miranda can you talk a little
bit about Vanessa and just anything
anything anything you want like who is
she what anything she's she's a badass
it was really awesome to read the script
especially as a woman you don't you
don't get to read many superhero movies
I have a badass romantic lead in it um
and she you know she gives him lip write
back and not necessarily the talking
card oh yeah she's just really awesome
she's a really you know a perfect match
to his crassness TJ yes TJ Miller Chris
Hardwick on this is my first time coming
thank you guys for a very crazy
yes seem weary but thank you I mean for
craps sake you would think HBO would
bring Silicon Valley to comic-con where
are we gonna bring a show about Northern
California Southern California
we're promoting an r-rated film the
first real r-rated superhero film on the
back of these it says please be aware
that many members of your audience may
be under 18 years of age
yo and to those of you I say you're
gonna [ __ ] love this movie yeah I
think we I think we I think we blew past
that barrier when we showed the first
part of this I think where everyone's
totally just say you kids have the
internet now you're desensitized to this
[ __ ] come on most of you've seen horses
[ __ ] before you kiss your first girl all
right good
well let's go there let's go there then
let's let's go there you know why TJ
because it's unbridled passion and I
just get bored of people after a while
right Oh Chris I eat your Seabiscuit and
Oh G
giddy up Teej I think you gave us a
sense of who we saw was without Brianna
what can you what could you tell us
about about your character um so I play
negasonic teenage warhead and she is
yeah and she is a 15 year old like
superhero in training she's Colossus
trainee and yeah she's pretty gothic
apathetic and she's a very strong young
superhero who's a female and I love her
excellent and
what was the experience like for you
coming in to the cast and where did you
where do you see yourself fitting in and
it was it was was the shoot grueling was
it fun was a dream come true it was so
fun um it was all fun and it was such a
dream come true because I may or may not
have had a huge crush on Ryan Reynolds
growing up
so what and this was my first like film
really so I had no idea what to expect
but it was so fun
and like the energy among everyone was
great and we all got along great and
yeah it was awesome I mean yeah you know
when when the lead character is like
that that actor really sets the tone of
the set I think so when it's someone
like you and it's someone who's nice and
fun you have TJ on there too I mean it
just it sounds oh yeah it's so easy to
be relaxed yeah it sounds like we're
going into overtime
yeah showed me this photo of her
Photoshop with that photo of Ryan where
he's like super 12-pack muscles and she
photoshopped herself into this photo
next to Ryan when she was in high school
she really did help I did I printed it
out what do you how do you what do you
say to that
I guess I was like I was her Joey
Lawrence myself into every Joey Lawrence
photo I could find and I feel yeah I
feel your pain well we have a special
guest Joey Lawrence is here that would
be amazing
oh that would be amazing whoa no he's
not a TV I'm sorry I was just I was I
was just doing a bit Chris I didn't mean
to toy with your heart TJ later we'll go
to an equestrian center you're really
gonna stir up some controversy with
these horses I'm gonna stir it up you
said the horse thing tear up like
stirrup well done oh well done good good
you've settled me with another [ __ ]
thank you this is what we do all day
this is the [ __ ] we do all day that's
good hey
all right no that was no you're right no
points for that one come on they're
chomping at the bit for the rest what
can you tell us about ajax ajax runs the
workshop the Wade Wilson comes into as a
terminally ill X Special Forces soldier
and we are we give him the superpowers
that turned him into Deadpool and um
he's very disrespectful and ungrateful
doesn't seem right do you feel you owe
them something you feel like they used
to oh them anything out for the super
pounder no you shouldn't you should see
what they turn me into though that's uh
I think it's a fair trade yeah let's
talk I want to talk to Jean about angel
dust what can you tell us about angel
does feel like we're creators with uh I
mean personally I have angel dust has a
little anger issues so we helped create
mr. Deadpool and it's it's been kind of
like a revolution I can I mean I'm
looking out here and it's just such a
massive event and it's such a pleasure
to be a part of it with this cast and
the crew and Tim Miller thank you for
giving me the opportunity to be a part
of it and thank you for allowing me the
outlet have my anger issues resolved
now when you obviously there's the
center rep there's a reverent tone that
is necessary to bring this on to the
screening you obviously chose the right
cast how much how much was there riffing
on the set and screwing around or how
much I mean did you allow that to go on
oh [ __ ] yeah I mean first of all I can't
stop it um Ryan does it non-stop and TJ
is completely uncontrollable
professional really even when I would
get angry at him and tell him to quit
[ __ ] around he would still do it but
everybody was great I mean we had a we
had a great set for a first time
director it's got to be one of the the
best experiences I could hope for
because we had no drama no difficulty
the studio
behind us for all the decisions they
they didn't question anything that we
did even though they probably should
have
I think Tim was the biggest drama unsub
yeah I'm a bit of a prima donna yeah
Ryan had to hug me at least twice a day
oh it's just a crybaby God he's such a
pervert to everything that he this guy
cries if he sees unadulterated rage like
it's like it like gets him it's true
Ryan did this scene where he he comes in
at a pivotal part of the movie that I
won't tell you about and he's just so
[ __ ] angry and Ryan he does this
thing and he's like dude I got like two
[ __ ] takes in me for this because I'm
there but it was brilliant and so I
choked up a little bit I found him
weeping and it was like none of the
funny dramatic stuff does it just the
pure rage you should direct the next
Hulk crying like a baby the whole time
behind the monitor I cry I cry for the
emotional style direct an episode of
Nancy Grace and then he got really
jealous and then Ryan gets really
jealous because in the third act marina
did this amazing scene and I and I
teared up again and then he did his side
of it and I was like yeah that was all
right no were there of were there plate
were there were there things that you
felt like oh well maybe this is one step
too far maybe this is one step too only
everyday there's stuff that I like would
get home I would be lying awake in bed
and I would text him just to say hey
that thing I said that extra joke at the
end of that scene when I'm walking out
of the cab could you make sure that's
never seen by anyone because there's a
number of organizations that will find
me there were there was a there was a
rewrite TJ Miller got involved in one of
the scenes and he wrote some of the
meanest jokes that I I that's where I
really said you know what we can't we
can't do this cuz this is funny [ __ ] but
it's [ __ ] mean it's just me
you you're laughing and crying and then
you go home and you literally cry it's
true I saw I saw Ryan's very strong I
don't know if you know ladies but he has
a very muscular body I think very strong
man he was really sweet because when Tim
would cry you'd hold him like a little
Trueba kitty yeah back and forth until
Tim no we'd all carry on the suit and
[ __ ] around so what can you what can you
say about this version of Deadpool if it
without obviously without giving away
too much but what can you say to people
what can they expect I mean I know we
got a glimpse of it in before what
they're saying but what well it's
everything you know that we loved about
the comics I mean it's we have a guy
that obviously is gonna break the fourth
wall you're obviously gonna see what I
and this is just my opinion but I think
the most faithful adaptation of a super
suit from a comic to a movie I've ever
seen
and that's Russ Shenko I gotta shout him
out we have we actually have the Merc
with the mouth the mouth is not at any
point in our film Sohn shot and was that
a condition you are not sewing this half
shot as a problem it was the only thing
I was even paid they just put they just
promised me that on this movie but and
yeah you have your you have your Merc
with the mouth you have the guy that is
doing his best to annoy the living [ __ ]
out of everyone around him 24/7 and you
know what Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick
the writers to where are they yeah yeah
they deserve a lot of credit because
this script Bar None is the best script
I've ever read I get choked up it's
this trip the script is great and they
and they were tireless about with me
trying to get this movie made with Ryan
we never let up with the studio just
constantly annoying them with emails to
please make this movie Rhett and Paul
were there the beside me the whole time
saying this is a best script we've ever
written and it needs to be done so Tim
you know I gotta say I you know I don't
we've never met before this moment I
didn't know this but I just I see this
crusty exterior and a chewy Center
inside that I really I really enjoy
about you
hottest middle-aged director work you
know but you have to know you have to
know that it's just it's important for
these people to know that this is that
important to you you know like this is a
very this is a very special and
important character to people and so if
you came out here like yeah we made this
hat jutsu remove it people like fog that
guy but you you know like you're
sensitive and you love it and it means
something to you and we actually have
some footage to show you guys because
because you're good and you've sat
through a lot of TJ and I'm making horse
puns and so I appreciate that
and let's show some never-before-seen
footage
because of Deadpool
well
I mean Oh
okay I'm gonna I first of all I don't
have powers that control this but you
know what I do have a microphone so
[ __ ] let's show it again
you
you